It's [music] God.
It's God.
>> [music and singing]
>> It's God.
Hey listen, man. You damn Christians,
y'all always lying.
>> [sighs]
>> The Trinity is not the Son, the Father,
and the Holy Ghost. They are not the
same person. When you read in Acts
chapter 7 and verse 55, the Bible says
that Christ was standing at the right
hand of his father. So, how the hell
they the same person?
Man, you Hebrew Israelites always lying,
man. Let me help you out. First of all,
no Christian ever said that the Father,
Son, and the Holy Spirit are the same
person. Man, you speaking out of
ignorance. This is what the Trinity is.
The Trinity is the concept that there's
one God who exists as three distinct
persons, the Father, the Son, and Holy
Spirit coexist, coeternal as the one
God, distinct with each other,
inseparable, and indivisible. That's
what the Trinity is. But then you went
to Acts chapter 7 as if you were
debunking the Trinity. Let me show you
how your own verse cut you. Watch this.
It says here, this is Acts chapter 7
verse 55, and it read, "But he, full of
the Holy Spirit, that's one, gazed into
heaven and saw the glory of God, that's
two, and Jesus Christ, that's three,
standing at the right hand of God." So,
the verse that you brought got the Holy
Spirit, the Father, and the Son all
present working together in the
salvation of Stephen. Watch this, it
gets better. Listen to this. Verse 59 it
says, "And as they were stoning Stephen,
he called out, 'Lord Jesus, receive my
spirit.' Wait, hold on a second,
Stephen. If you think that Jesus is God,
then you it makes sense for you to call
out to him, but if he's not God, then
you're committing idolatry. Why would a
monotheistic Jew be calling out to a
creature if that thing ain't God? So, of
course Stephen here is demonstrating
that Jesus is God because he can call
and pray out to him and ask him to
receive his spirit. Watch this, it gets
better. It says, "And falling to his
knees, he cried out with a loud voice,
'Lord, do not hold this sin against
them.' And when he said this, he fell
asleep." So, hold on a second, so
Stephen believes Christ has the
authority, has the power to withhold
sin, to forgive or not forgive, to have
mercy on who he has mercy on? Sounds
like God to me. Man, you Hebrew
Israelites always lying, man. Hey, so we
proven to you that what? The Christian
church has been lying to you blacks,
Hispanics, and Native Americans for
centuries. Christ is a black man
according to Revelation 1 and 14. Now
you know.
There you go again with them lies. Hey
baby, what's the only thing we do around
here? We just read, man. That's it. So,
let's go ahead, we're just going to get
into this. This is Revelation 1, this is
what he talking about right here, man.
So, when we talking about Revelation 1,
let's see if he telling the truth right
here. So, it says in verse 14, it says,
"The hairs of his head were white like
wool." Wait, hold on a second. It says
white like wool, like that of snow. So,
it's describing his hair, the color of
his hair, not the texture of his hair.
Man, what y'all over here talking about?
What y'all reading, dog? Let's see,
let's keep going. It says here, it says,
"His feet were like burnished bronze,
refined in a furnace." So, his feet were
burned? Are we taking this stuff
literal? Was his feet actually burned in
a furnace? Nah. Let's keep reading. "And
his voice was like a roar of many
waters. In his right hand he held seven
stars. From his mouth came a sharp
two-edged sword." So, what our Hebrew
Israelites want us to believe is that
Jesus has a literal sword in his mouth
since all of Revelation that we talking
about is all literal. That's how dumb
these dudes want y'all sounding. But
since we're in Revelation, let me show
y'all something real quick.
Now, let's see what Jesus is talking
about over here in Revelation 22. He
says in verse 12 and 13, "Look, I am
coming quickly, and my reward is with me
to repay each person according to what
he has done." Watch this. "I am the
Alpha and the Omega, the first and the
last, the beginning and the end." Now,
why is this important? Because this is
reflecting what Yahweh, the Most High,
says in the Tanakh. Y'all are also
Hebrew Israelites. So, y'all supposed to
like this Tanakh. This going to cut you.
Watch this, we going to go over there to
Isaiah 41. In Isaiah 41 verse 4, this is
what it says,
"Who has performed and done this,
calling the generations from the
beginning? I, the Lord, am the first and
with the last I am he." It don't stop
there, it keeps getting better. Isaiah
44 verse 6, "This is what Yahweh, the
King of Israel and its Redeemer, the
Lord of hosts, says, 'I am the first and
I am the last, there is no God but me.'"
So, right here we got Jesus claiming to
be the first and the last, which means
that he is Yahweh, the Most High God,
the same God that revealed himself in
the Tanakh. Man, quit playing with me.
So, another lie that these lying
Christians be saying is the law of God
has done away with. But when you read
Romans 3 and 31, it tells you that we
didn't make void the law through faith.
Nay, we establish the law. So, you lying
Christians, man, fix your face.
Now, I'mma give y'all a real nice lesson
in culinary arts. Whenever a Hebrew
Israelite is quoting a verse, hold that
man to the context because as one man,
one dead man told me that if you hold
them to the context, he's going to die.
So, now let's see what the context of
Romans 3 is talking about. This going to
Y'all, I'm telling you right now, this
is the end-all, be-all finisher. Watch
this. Romans chapter 3, we're going to
read verse 20. It says, "For by works of
the law, no human being will be
justified in his sight, since through
the law comes knowledge of sin." So,
what is the purpose of the law? It's to
show you your sin, not to justify you
because you can't be justified through
works of the law. So, that's a cut right
there, but it gets better. Let's keep
going. Verse 21, "But now, the
righteousness of God has been manifested
apart from the law, although the law and
the prophets bear witness to it, the
righteousness of God through faith in
Jesus Christ for all who believe." I
can't believe that you came here, bro.
You really came to Romans chapter 3 to
try to prove that Christians be lying,
but all we're showing here is that you
guys be lying, the Hebrew Israelites.
They lying to you, bro. They trained you
up in a lie. But I'm not done. Let's
keep reading, let's see what this says.
"Then what becomes of our boasting? It
is excluded. By what kind of law?
By a law of works? No, but by the law of
faith." Boom. You see what I'm talking
about? What is the law that we uphold?
Is it the law of Moses? Is it the law of
works? No, but it's the law of the
Messiah, the law of faith, not of your
works cuz that doesn't justify you. It's
your faith that justifies you. Let's
keep reading the context because he's
already dead by now, but let's keep
stomping on him. Verse 28, "For we hold
that one is justified by faith apart
from works of the law. Or is God the God
of the Jews only? Is he not the God of
the Gentiles also? Yes, of the Gentiles
also." So, with this being said, I just
got one little piece of advice for you.
Go on and fix your face.